The ocean.
It covers three quarters of our planet.
It gives us the oxygen we breathe.
It regulates our climate.
It feeds us.
The ocean gives us clean energy.
It offers new medicines.
For millions, it provides a livelihood.
For millions more, it provides life.
The ocean is owned by no one,
but shared by everyone.
My ocean
But the ocean is under pressure.
Urgent action is needed.
This October global actors will meet in Malta.
They know that protecting the seas
means protecting our future.
Now, it is the turn of the European Union
to host the 'Our Ocean' conference.
Together we will commit to new actions
to protect marine life.
To tackle marine litter.
To use our ocean sustainably.
Now more than ever,
my ocean is our ocean